So we already went through a lot of the allegations
made and Marielle Trump's book about Donald
Trump.
Trump was verbally abused by his dad.
Wouldn't be surprising.
He treats people like crap.
Often people repeat what they grew up around.
Trump paid someone to take his essay t's new
claim, but wouldn't be hugely surprising.
Trump has a learning disability.
It's a new take on Trump's cognitive.
Appearing cognitively compromised would not
be hugely surprising.
Trump's not really religious.
He only goes to church when there's a camera
there or it's advantageous in some way.
I mean, like none of the claims were very
surprising.
But the people around Donald Trump have reacted
explosively to the forthcoming publication
of this book.
First, you have Trump adviser Kellyanne Conway,
who just lost it on Fox News over this book.
She actually threatened members of the media
saying, quote, I believe family matters should
be family matters, which is that there's a
whole other story there where she and her
husband have been publicly tweeting stuff
related to their daughter.
But that that's a different story.
I believe family matters should be family
matters.
I think the thin skinned, troubled living
in a glass house, mainstream media members
who think people's families are their business
ought to really think thrice the next time
they do that, sort of throwing in a thinly
veiled threat at the media.
There is Kellyanne Conway, of course, you
might notice not actually refuting any of
the allegations that are made in Mary Trump's
book.
Then Trump press secretary Kaley McKenny had
a hilarious brief statement about this, saying,
I have not seen the book and it's filled with
lies.
Wait, so you didn't see it, but you know what's
in it.
Listen very, very carefully here.
And this is going to be an instructive moment
for us.
I no response other than a book of falsehoods,
and that's not it.
Psychologists have the this narcissistic with
a means of self aggrandizement, all sorts
of values.
It's ridiculous, absurd allegations that have
an absolute no bearing, in truth, I have yet
to see the book, but it is a book of falsehoods.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
I have yet to see the book, but it's a book
of falsehoods, so this is a great opportunity
to show you how this administration tries
to bully the media and to foment the narrative
of fake news even when it doesn't exist.
The narrative that reporters are biased is
always the priority for this administration.
McKenney clearly said there.
I have yet to see the book, but it is a book
of falsehoods.
ABC reporter Jonathan Karl quoted her verbatim
tweeting, quote, Press secretary offers an
interesting take on the Mary Trump book.
I have yet to see the book, but it is a book
of falsehood.
So that's Jonathan Karl quoting Kaley McKenny
verbatim.
Kayla McKenny.
Caitlin McKenny tweets in response.
Don't be disingenuous.
Jonathan Karl.
Though I don't possess a physical copy of
the fictitious book, since I'm not in the
press corps, my inbox has been flooded with
the false claims and excerpts from the book.
You know how this works.
And yet, here you are.
But again, her claim was not.
I've not seen a physical copy of the book,
but I know what's in it and it's filled with
lies.
And here are the specific lies.
Her claim wasn't I haven't seen the book,
but I know what's in it and thus I'm able
to intelligently comment on it.
Her claim was only I haven't seen the book
and it's a book of falsehoods.
And Jonathan Karl quoted her verbatim.
But more importantly, this is how they turn
the narrative on the reporter.
If there are lies in the book, tell us which
are the lies.
And as of right now, they have not substantively
refuted any of the claims.
All of the claims are completely consistent
with everything we know about Donald Trump.
We say it's a lie.
Or Trump says it's a lie.
It's not really anything.
And it's instructive in how they turn this
completely around and make it about the reporter,
make it about the fake news media when really
I mean, I don't I don't want to deflate the
importance of this book because it's a powerful
book to hear from someone that that was an
insider to the Trump family, although she's
now estranged.
But nothing in the book is even that notable
because it's all so in line with what we've
observed from Donald Trump.
And when they come out and just say it's all
lies.
Well, is it because it all sounds super consistent
in the picture it paints of an insecure, narcissistic
man with delusions of grandeur, willing to
do whatever he believes in the moment will
help him get ahead.
And that's really the picture that we've that's
the Donald Trump we've known.
And that's exactly the picture that's painted
in the book.
And so far, no specific refutation of anything
that is in there.
We're going to take a break.
And coming up after the break, we're going
to talk about a Mississippi election commissioner
who is furious that, quote, the blacks
plan
to vote yes.
That's coming up next.